let's build up some objects that have a
lot of similarities so that we can see
how prototype chains might help us on
the right here i'll show a picture of
the objects that we're creating as we go
and the relationships that they develop
here we have a property lookup on the
gold object let's consider every step of
what happens when we do a property
lookup for the key a on this object the
interpreter kicks off an investigation
as to whether or not the gold object has
the property we're looking for upon
inspecting the object the interpreter
can tell that there is a pair available
in this object that has the key a the
value that's associated with that pair
is 1 and so the result of this lookup
expression is going to be 1. in this
case our logging system would log the
value 1 out to the screen somewhere my
code assumes that there is some function
called log that already exists in most
environments you would call it
console.log
but let's take a look at what happens
when we ask for a property that we know
the object doesn't have first that
property lookup arrives at the object
and then the interpreter acknowledges
the failure by providing undefined in
response to this attempted lookup for z
and so the lookup for z on the gold
object results in undefined which is
what ultimately gets logged to the
screen